all right so we're back we got some
gifts who got to show off yeah I'm not a
Jenny go first these all came from
Sophie yes we got a big box from Sophie
yesterday family we recorded the show
yeah I was like oh what's that
so if you already asked me if you had
had something like this I said no but
then she sent me some stuff too I didn't
you know I had no idea guys yes pretty
cool so well it said we just talked
about this [ __ ] yes well it's funny
because I didn't even know and like I
didn't know any of this [ __ ] was gonna
happen but check it out y'all
she sent me all five of the Duran Duran
yeah figures yeah there's Roger yeah
Nick yeah yeah what outfits from what
era is this wrong either from I couldn't
remember these are they're not from the
planet Earth video because Simon had
dark hair in that one and also we're
like kind of a more puffy new romantic
style shirt these were either from there
Simon these are either from the careless
memories video or the my own way
yeah I couldn't remember but it was one
of those two because I remember like the
little stripes and stuff you know what I
mean mmm whereas like you know the
planet Earth video which is the more
iconic one probably but they looked a
lot more new romantic and that one and
like I said Simon's hair was still
pretty dark yeah but and then she sent
me check this out and so excited it's
Eddie
the killers album [ __ ] you yeah it's
awesome one and then Eddie off-putting
peace of mind out I can't believe they
have pops of everybody man and then the
third one this one here is great check
this out it's [ __ ] Billy yeah it's
[ __ ] I'll say gary's cuz like look
nose is dry there and ones let me show
that make we're in zone again cuz i
don't think he got on the camera that
good but it's like pop figures don't
normally have mouths but i guess because
I mean Billy Idol is like that's one of
his
of distinguishing features yes snarl so
they had to like I love that they had to
sing with Eddie to some of the Annie
from iron made that what yeah yeah
[ __ ] Billy understood the [ __ ] even
though he spent a lot of his time in
California Billy was the probably one of
the only British rednecks here's all my
he loved [ __ ] Elvis you know oh they
have rednecks over there they just don't
really call but from the South yeah no
no he like he'd like [ __ ] from like
Mississippi and Alabama yeah look and
he's wearing he was wearing but a
[ __ ] Confederate flags and stuff it
didn't really have anything to do you
know of course you know in that era you
know there wasn't like a connotation of
[ __ ] you know him being racist or
anything that's not what he was doing
just that
he liked anything that was [ __ ]
southern southern so he liked that Mason
you know anything's south of the
mason-dixon line he he drank [ __ ]
what rebel yell is actually like that's
like a southern with it's like a
southern whiskey even though it doesn't
come from the south they were making it
up north but I think at one time in the
past it was something from the south but
it was me it ended up getting subbed out
to a distillery up north but yeah rebel
yell so [ __ ] basically a cheap
southern whiskey yeah yeah kind of like
Wild Turkey
yeah I've seen it before is nasty when I
was a kid that was kind of like
Thunderbird the Thunderbird of [ __ ]
whiskey yeah yeah some northerners were
selling to rednecks
though cuz they're just like every by
the time they get to this they'll be G
yeah although I don't think it's the
exact same rebel yell of what you know
back then well yeah because I think
elations of everything yeah I think
modern rebel yells probably a lot better
than rebel yell from the [ __ ] 80s I
feel like a lot of things food and Drita
specifically have had to be better
nowadays because people are a lot more
discerning what yeah net and that name
brand has a little bit of recognition so
it better be decent yeah no because that
would be one thing like if you know so I
want to drink it cuz it's a song and
it's like oh yeah
yeah you know in the song yeah I can
well well yeah man whiskey was involved
that's what he's talking about and you
know and he riding motorcycles you know
[ __ ] Billy like motorcycles and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] this all he had this [ __ ]
kind of punk rock [ __ ] romantic idea
of being in the south on a motorcycle
like on a ninja you know or KZ K Z 1000
or somethin and being outside on the
state lines [ __ ] turn in holy water
into wine living by camp fire sighs it's
you can't just do that dressed in
leathers though without a bunch of gear
but you know well maybe you can't if
you're a punk rocker what summer yes
that was the that was what he was he was
into I [ __ ] in a big Billy Idol fan
yeah well the funny thing is that like I
said and we had been taught and we had
talked about Duran Duran on the side
track show yesterday and so I and I did
not know cuz when we recorded the show
like we hadn't got the box and like I
guess it was still out on the porch and
so I was like really really excited and
you know it's really weird when I went
for my walk this morning and I was
listen to my headphones I like my phone
that's got all the music on it it played
like almost all Duran Duran songs like
because I have it unlike a random
shuffle but yeah it's like so I'm like
walking around I just like playing wild
boys and it's playing like is there
something I should know yeah we're not
gonna take them out of the box though
half the damn value of a Pop's figure is
the damn box because now I can't
remember I'm pretty sure this is from
the my own way video my be let me see
the one with the red background I like
the bullfighting kind of machine you see
because I kind of feel like John Taylor
had the little red thing like around his
waist during that but it could have been
careless memories too because I think
they those videos I think were made bike
right around the same time period and
they still they had the same like little
fashion choices because they went a
little slicker like I think that might
be off of careless memories cuz I
remember that red sash nothing I'm
saying and I say I was bothering me
because I couldn't remember it and I was
like sitting there going oh man yeah you
know I mean oh I wanted to say this for
just apropos of nothing
do you remember I think a while back we
mentioned that Glenn Danzig had made a
movie yeah called Veronica yeah we
looked at the trailer it looked terrible
Wow okay I watched Chris stuckman who is
a movie reviewer that I love he did a
what he calls a hilarious 'ti review
which he only does like for the
shittiest movies and you guys go watch
the don't watch the actual movie because
it looks wretched and like not in a way
that's like oh it's so bad it's good it
looked painful
to sit through and I guess he found it
painful to sit through to the the review
is half an hour and he had to drink
three shots of whiskey he just couldn't
stick well just actually just the just a
trailer I mean sueded [ __ ] poor
quality I mean and people are saying and
like I saw some of the people in the
comments they're like well you know Glen
is a big fan of like Ed Wood and all
this other kind of stuff so maybe he did
it on purpose because he was trying to
get like the Tommy why's oh the room
kind of thing where it's like the movie
so shitty that it becomes famous because
everybody watches it so that he made it
bad on purpose I don't know from the
clips that I was looking at it doesn't
look to me like he made it bad on
purpose I mean I could be totally wrong
about it but one it's like all and I
somebody like in the in the comments
described it as they're like this is
like all like the build-up in a porn
movie without the actual Emporium it's
actually three stories it's like an
anthology it kind of yeah well each one
every time they showed a woman in there
she had huge implants she look like a
porn star they were porn stars okay yeah
well I can understand that I mean that's
that's what he would put in there but
like I said part of the reason why a
movie can be so bad it's good they're
high effort yeah and I mean it would
really did put effort in a certain way
Robbie yeah you know it's just kind of
like it's kind of like we were talking
about you know a Rudy Rae movie yeah we
watch stuff there's a lot of effort in
them well yeah they're good oh well
they're good in terms of like they're
entertaining
yeah all right the quality isn't all
that great but stuff happens in them and
they really cared about what he was
making and they didn't get better as
they go if you don't have any effort in
it it's never gonna have that feel so
bad it's good dynamic yeah you have that
it has to have been something that was
you put effort into that maybe looking
at this one by the trailer it looks like
there was no effort put in it looks and
honestly from the clips because Chris
Stockman played likes significant amount
of clips like from the movies and he's a
filmmaker too so he like could point out
where there was mistakes and stuff and
he's like this basically looks like
somebody that didn't know how to make a
movie he's like every single scene he's
like there's a scene they all go on too
long and you can tell by the actors
faces that they're waiting for Glenn to
say cut right think it's just like goes
on like 15 20 seconds longer and they'd
look really awkward he's like every
single scene ends with a fade it's like
he doesn't know how to edit things he
doesn't know and he's like him Plus even
though these are three distinct stories
he's like nothing happens in them it's
just like a series of people doing
things it doesn't mean anything there's
no conflict
maybe there's no anything maybe he did
do it on purpose but that's not how you
do it
well no like I said there's the best the
best movies like that you know kind of
stray into like so bad it's good
territory I make the best MST episodes
for example are ones where you can tell
that this was someone's like passion
projects only they had no clue what
they're doing or they did have a clue
but they didn't have the money to get it
done that that's an Asst and they just
tried to okay look we don't have the
special effects we're just gonna pretend
yeah you know and there has to be heart
in the movie for it to be so bad it's
good
yeah I'm just just you know and what if
it we can't do that on purpose yeah if
you set out to do that on purpose like
you're saying oh he did it on purpose
that's not how it happens no you're not
gonna get that time yeah it's accidental
the reason the room is so delightful is
because Tommy Tommy Wiseau is a crazy
person and thought that he was making a
good movie yeah and well it's sad but in
comparison like the room looks a lot
more competent than declined and
everyone does like just from a
filmmaking stamp
the special effects look bad like the
CGI looks bad it's like the editing is
bad the acting is terrible like the
framing is terrible it's like it looks
like they just didn't care it just
looked like the Lee Roy no one Glen and
his [ __ ] attitude dude
the dude's got attitude yeah I'm not
gonna say he's a dick I haven't met him
personally chances are he's trolling
yeah it's probably what are you doing is
trolling but that doesn't make the movie
a success an artistic success yeah you
know I'm gonna make it bad not to just
to troll them it's not gonna be
effective it's very hard to make I mean
it's hard to make a good movie but it's
hard to make a bad really perfect
exactly sorry hard to make what he's
doing on purpose very hard to make a
movie this Bad's good one thing that
made me laugh would be he's just like
[ __ ] you I'm gonna make it bad
I'm gonna make it bad and and might be
that cuz he's a dick
dude's a serious dick because what what
happened one of the things that made me
laugh and cringe simultaneously was that
on the on the Chris segment video he
showed like a clip of glenn danzig like
he was at some panel like a horror con
or something and they were asking him
about this movie and one he was like
super serious about it for some reason
everybody in the movie is supposed to be
French even they're all American actors
so he's talking about how they hired a
serious dialect coach even though the
accents and they're just like atrocious
but then he's like talking about because
they were talking about the second
segment and as soon as like they said
what it was about I said oh it's like
eyes without a face the George Franju
movie and then they show a clip of Glenn
like talking about how it wasn't homage
to that and because he can't just say
eyes without a face he had to say it in
like the French title yeah light and
like he was educating everyone about it
I said if you're any horror fan worth
their salt has seen eyes without a face
yeah you know what I mean it's a classic
so the fact that he just like very
douching Lee was like explaining it and
he had without a face the fact that he
was like douching Lee explaining it to a
roomful of horror fans and that he like
was being all like he differentiate idol
first
and I was just kind of like like my eyes
just rolled back in my head and I was
like okay but yeah it's like I had seen
it when I first saw it come up like on
the rental thing or whatever I didn't
realize that it was Glenn Danzig but
then when I found out later on and that
I've seen clips of it since then I'm
like wow but I got a hint I got a hand I
got in a fun bad way I got to hand it to
Glenn though you know I saw him live
like in Boston back and we're right when
I got out of the army I think was the it
was the how the gals kilt or I was right
up front man [ __ ] that axis it was
either access or violence the Venus de
Milo I forgot they're right next door to
each other right outside Fenway in
Boston
man he's [ __ ] badass life he's [ __ ]
great life at least he was back then I
haven't seen him in a long time but you
know there man he was [ __ ] fantastic
and when he's all point he's on point
but we're talking about music
yeah um character he comes off as a dick
he does that comes off as I mean I don't
know I don't know I mean every interview
I saw with him he was just kind of like
a very d- kind of a dick and yeah just
like man [ __ ] he's here dude be a man
but he just don't write the same way
that Steven Seagal comes around yeah
exact rice is very self-important yeah
and he takes himself too seriously he
doesn't have a sense of humor about
himself it's like you can't like joke
with him or anything because he thinks
everything he does is awesome and if
you're picking on him you're just a
hater and and every question you ask him
he goes like yes before even as bad it's
like if that that's what that was the
kind of the tone when he started talking
about eyes without a face and I was just
like Glenn yeah we've seen eyes without
a face yeah holy crap it's like
everybody knows that that's what was in
homage to don't be up to there like
trying to announce it all French I like
the French title who's Liz you know
whatever and I'm like man shut the [ __ ]
up ya little broken down house right
there [ __ ] in one of those el Los
Angeles suburbs and with cats tearing up
all this [ __ ] you know I mean I thought
[ __ ] Glenn Danzig would live in a
damn mansion he did lived in a white
trash man white-trash paradise like some
kid would live at ranch and he sold that
you know and in that area that was the
most
million dollar home here it would be
like nothing to be something they tear
down you know thing is that glenn danzig
made a terrible movie this year and also
fred durst made a [ __ ] terrible movie
this year the fanatic or whatever that
one that had John Travolta in it and
it's like I'm thinking about it and I'm
like well maybe I should stop picking on
Rob Zombie for like some of his movies
being shitty because like yeah he's a
musician but most of his movies are
actually pretty good
you can watch it yeah yeah people you
know some people are multi-talented and
some yeah they're just good at one thing
and that's fine yeah what wouldn't what
Glenn is good at his [ __ ] singing
yeah he's he's good at that just don't
listen to him and don't [ __ ] you know
I don't take his don't take I can
understand because it's like you know I
like doing lots of different things too
I like writing I like doing my design
and stuff like that but I am self-aware
enough to know that I do not know how to
make a movie we know a guy like this
he's [ __ ] great you know on stage and
he's got good album we're not gonna mid
name his name puts on a good show I can
get along with it but nobody else does
and I understand why you know I mean
yeah he comes off like gland antic
they're very they come across as very
because they think they're better than
everyone I guess yeah I don't know what
defense mechanism that what I'm that's
what I was just gonna say actually
during insecure and so they come across
as like they want to be better than
everyone and so they come across as
really condescending yeah but there for
some reason don't have the [ __ ] the
wherewithal to realize that people see
through that exactly what that that's my
Steven Seagal like it's on my nerve so
much because I'm like it seems really
obvious to everyone else that he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] then he's like really
really insecure and useless like that
wildly overcompensating and it's like
everybody knows that but him it's like
yeah thing is you say something sideways
the [ __ ] to uh to Seagal he'll [ __ ]
put you in a headlock or throw you up
against the wall or something the dude
six-foot some probably yeah and you know
if you're smaller than him he'll he'll
beat up on you he's a bully well yeah I
don't think I don't think don't think
like that glance about my size actually
he's not a big not a big dude height
wise yeah and I don't he got knocked out
that one time although anybody can knock
anybody out really that's not really
sanding if you're ready for me I think I
think in that video he got set up that
guy from that band they were already
conveniently [ __ ] filming it and it
looks like they made that thing happened
right although Glenn [ __ ] lost his
cool you got a made of [ __ ] and just
that tone alone you use a tone like that
there are guys out there that will just
knock you out
yeah just for using that tone they'll
swing not everybody [ __ ] is uh you
know not everyone is mild-mannered not
everyone's real polite with their fists
and you say something sideways use the
wrong tone or use the wrong facial
expression they just [ __ ] punch you
right in the sweet spot yeah you know I
guess he wasn't used to that he cuz he
you know I mean he didn't Bob duck or
weave it was just pow if I was gonna use
a tone like that I'd have been on guard
using it you know man like this I would
expect somebody to [ __ ] swing yeah
you can't just go around being a douche
all the time right I'm gonna knock your
block oh yeah and that guy's if that guy
was a least a foot taller yeah so you
know they got he had reach on him that's
the thing I think that a lot of people
that just go around being douches with
impunity have never gotten punched yeah
I guess so I don't I don't think Lana's
like somebody who goes out there and
fights all the time yeah cuz he'd
probably lose you know unless so but you
know but he got pretty big for a while
yeah yeah it was not you know I I'm a
student of all that you know it he had
he I'm gonna say he had some help some
chemical help yeah to get that yeah um
but he didn't maintain you still have to
lift the weight yeah you know you can't
just take something take some injections
and get huge you got a [ __ ] we got al
if you stop doing you'll get bad yeah
you'll get a fattest [ __ ] if you take
ever take roids and don't do anything
you just get fat
yeah yeah which you know a lot of people
have done that too yeah yeah well that
happens a lot with um you know athletes
and stuff like that especially if they
get injured yeah just like that to heal
up I get fat yeah punches you're out yes
sir but true but yes so uh I've got to
talk about I gotta give a shout-out to
the new subscribers the new patrons the
agents we actually will probably do that
on the Regular Show too but um that but
that won't come out till Tuesday so I
just want to because we just got like a
couple of new people yes and then some
British people paid us some money and
we're gonna get to that where you get
down yeah cuz like I said I don't have
any notes for this one so like I didn't
write cuz I wrote on everyone's name but
really all I had to say today oh there
is something else the [ __ ] streaming
wars have begun paramount is I think no
it's Universal Universal is banned from
AMC they can't show into their movies
there and then the other studios are
like okay we won't released Street
because and the reason why Universal got
banned is because they put out that
trolls movie they streamed that and the
[ __ ] numbers came back [ __ ]
awesome and those studios don't really
need those theaters but the theaters
don't want to know that so they're
trying to muscle trying to throw the
dick down and the other studios have
told told AMC no no no we won't release
the streaming we're gonna get we're
gonna give you guys you know first shout
the movies the thing is as a man AMC is
in serious [ __ ] problem financial
trouble
I don't think AMC's gonna survive anyway
you know the bankruptcies and everything
that they have going on streaming is the
way of the future I mean [ __ ] you
have and then you have AMC coming out
[ __ ] bragging about how well
everybody knows the real way to see a
movie is on the big screen and this is
the way it's always gonna be but that's
the kind of [ __ ] blockbuster was saying
before Netflix [ __ ] tour I'm a new
booty hole okay
went up in that booty yes I just had
like a really funny mental image of like
a little redneck
and like getting getting rolled into its
you've been like that's what happened to
[ __ ] AMC is gonna AMC and somebody's
theater chains are gonna end up being
the blockbuster of the [ __ ] 2020s
just watch perhaps it does really seem
like it's a shame because I really like
you know the movie going experience but
I do think it will probably contract to
a point where that I think though there
will still be like specialty in movie
theaters but I think like the multiplex
that's gone might not be able to the
problem is is that there's there's too
much competition over movies there's
things other than movies that are
[ __ ] taking the money way like video
games and YouTube and then once you get
the theater chains involved they want
too big of a cut all right yeah
so what that means is is that you have
to make these gigantic [ __ ] tentpole
movies that are [ __ ] worth hundreds
of millions of dollars just to make and
better hope that they make a billion and
if you they don't make a billion dollars
then nobody makes any money it's just
totally [ __ ] crazy that's not how you
do it if you cut out the theaters you
can make a movie for a hundred million
dollars and then stream it and get all
of your money back as a studio but the
[ __ ] you need them for it what do you
need in you know what do you and and
that's what happened with that dam
trolls movie what's called trolls the
world tour world tour I remember you
know what I remember seeing previews for
that because we went and saw some
animated movies like Wonder Park and
stuff like that and I think we saw the
trailer for this I didn't see the first
one um he the kids movie it honestly
surprises me that it's doing really well
it was a mediocre release that you
thought was not gonna make anything look
bad but it didn't look that great either
this is what Universal thought I was at
Universal yeah I'm thinking the
universal or paramount which one is it
[ __ ] anyway the studio that made that I
think it was Universal the studio that
made it released it direct just
streaming because they thought it was a
mediocre release they didn't expect to
make anything on it not only did they
make it more people saw that then they
saw part one yeah okay by a wide margin
and the studio kept
much more of the money to the ticket
sales so they were like what the [ __ ] we
need a theatres for yeah and they're
absolutely right it's less risky just if
I can send that [ __ ] out on I think
probably they will make a lot more with
family movies because these dream up
well no because what I was gonna say was
that you know paying $20 for one movie
yeah may seem excessive for like one
person but all the kids if you got like
a whole family yeah that's like a fifth
of the cost yeah taking them all to the
theater and they can all sit and watch
the same movie for $20 and what AMC said
was [ __ ] just arrogant you know
seeing movies in the theater is the real
way to see movies as if the average
person now doesn't have a huge HD Smart
TV and surround surround sound in their
home yeah it's the same size or bigger
if you sit in front of it if you're
sitting way off to the back it might
look a little bit smaller but if I'm
sitting in front of that TV on that
little thing that I have it's bigger
than the screen would be yeah if I was
in a theater and the audio is just as
good and I don't say the audio isn't as
good as say like Dolby but I could buy a
system like that that would damn [ __ ]
rattle the damn windows yeah so you know
I rented rattle the chair because that's
what the Dolby thing was doing the chair
it's just stupid you know I mean they're
they're grasping for straws the the
theaters are gonna end up being the
video the home video rental stores of
the 2020s they're gonna they're gonna go
under probably I think it's gonna
contract to a more specialty type thing
because like I said there are still you
know places where you can buy like vinyl
records and stuff like that it's not a
massive mainstream thing but it's still
enough of a niche that you can run a
small business doing that so I think
that'll probably happen like three art
small art house theaters yeah if like
that maybe like you know a chain like
I'm in like Alamo Drafthouse or you know
like that will probably survive because
they show like you know they do like
theme nights they show older movies
newer movies they have a restaurant
attached and when we went up at AMC some
of the biggest night
that we went that were during the
matinee were the rish Owings of old
movies so saw alien one man who's
[ __ ] the theaters packed same with
the shining same with the shadow is that
all yeah so you can show old movies you
know sir new movies I had read that AMC
was actually gonna start doing that like
if they reopened because they said well
just until because they said look
there's not a lot of new movies coming
out so it's like not much they could do
but they could show I mean to all the
Terminator me I mean I can fathom events
puts most of that on so they probably
get a cut of that I'm not sure how that
works I know fathom events does because
they do the RiffTrax live so I'm
assuming that you know a lot of money is
gonna have to the studios are gonna
realize that they don't have to make 150
million dollar movie that they can go in
there and make a fifty million dollar
movie and have the end result look even
as good as the hundred and fifty million
dollar movie and release it directed DVD
director streaming and they make more
profit off of that because they don't
have to share to tick the sales as much
and they'll be able to make more of them
per year that's what I think is gonna
happen well yeah I definitely think it's
gonna go more toward like small your
smaller shows value and each one of them
more targeted towards yes they don't
have to worry about all this
generalization and yet animal trying
right and start instead of trying to
make a 250 million dollar movie that
appeals to everybody know yeah you know
make a 10 million dollar movie a 30
million dollar that just appeals to how
our whatever percent it can bring back
badass little science fiction movies and
bad as little westerns or whatever
samurai movies anything yeah because
you're gonna get enough people like to
make money back like and it's all
streaming and it's it's up there for
[ __ ] years making money for you yeah
yeah I mean because yeah once it's up
dance is up there sup there yeah so and
why am i right well because like they're
still when you go through like the xbox
rental say yeah it's like yeah most of
the most of the rentals like cuz you can
you know you can categorize by like how
many times it's been rented and stuff
most of them are new but there's a bunch
of old ones in there too so a lot of
people are still renting yeah old movies
and you can get like the whole alien
series in the package for $30
yeah or retina by it forever or I think
there's ways where you can rent the
whole package yeah well if you make a
movie now you know it will be up there
for years and years and years so maybe
you didn't get that big influx of cash
on [ __ ] you know the day that you
released it but over time it makes a lot
of damn money for you you didn't yeah
maybe maybe if it's a good movie it gets
good word of mouth yeah you know people
like picking up a one thing are the most
profitable movies of all times was road
warrior it wasn't over the time it just
yeah cuz Eaton spent a whole all that
much on it but it just made a [ __ ] ton
of movies [ __ ] ton of money especially
during the VHS rental era yeah I think a
lot of movies from the 70s kind of got a
renewed life like when VHS came out
because you know everybody VHS was a new
thing and everybody had just got like
VCRs and beta maxes or whatever in their
[ __ ] house and it was like this
novelty yeah and a lot of the bigger
studios
even back then were kind of slow on the
uptake and they didn't really want to
release the movies to to VHS so that
kind of left a gap in the market for all
of these smaller like independent movie
houses to put out these kind of cheap
Jack's like horror sci-fi type of movies
or like foreign movies that they like
redubbed and various things like that
and they made a whole bunch of money
back that way and what was weird about
the VHS era is that you had to go down
and rent those VHS VHS tapes because you
couldn't recopy one on your own you
couldn't you you know you we didn't have
it they didn't sell the technology to
copy a damn tape yeah well like a copy
of a movie was like a hundred bucks yeah
come on [ __ ] take remember that I
remember that if you owned it now you
were like [ __ ] damn you own that
movie so but what that meant for the
rentals is that you know I must have
rented [ __ ] road warrior thirty times
yeah you know I mean yeah and they got
it they got a cut of that every time I
[ __ ] rented that movie
I guess that studio might have gotten a
dollar yeah yeah it was you know what
though I have to say that for a while
like we had a VCR that had
you know that you could record from one
tape to another some of the tapes
especially like the bigger titles had
macrovision but we had a thing where it
would work around that so I could
actually rent a movie and record it and
keep it yeah which you know I thought
you needed two players a player and a
recorder you did no well no because I
had a VCR that had two and you could
record from once a day that's right I
remember you need a TV
eventually you needed two VCRs yeah you
could collect you connect them with a
cable the hell how um when did that come
out I don't really remember it must have
been mid to late 80s okay yeah because I
remember the first time I saw that I was
quite impressed yeah we had one unit
that had two and you could record from
one to the other
you could you could record directly off
a TV when they came out
yeah but recording from one tape to
another was a big deal when I saw
somebody do it I was like Dan that's
cheating yeah it was the way I did that
I was thinking that she because they
were Vitt they were renting a [ __ ]
movie yeah and then copying the room
like I said I think well for a time you
could do that kind of you know with
impunity but then after a while the
students were like hey and they invented
macro revision which was in theory
supposed to keep you from recording them
like you could record it but it would
just come out like you cannot like that
you cannot start progress of technology
we had a worker yeah they can ask that
progress especially nowadays now with
the technology that's out there you
can't you can eventually you will be
able to make chemicals or drugs or what
anything through some kind of a dam some
kind of famine synthesizer that's that's
what's gonna be like Star Trek and that
protein synthesizer will actually be
like your refrigerator where you put a
bunch of proteins in the top and it
synthesizes and makes any food that you
want then you cook see that's what I'm
actually what I'm excited about that
Star Trek shape we can just go into the
cafeteria and you can just like tell the
thing looks like whatever you want and
whatever what it'll do is they'll take
proteins and weird [ __ ] like that and
[ __ ] just like a 3d printer will
start assembly s assembly
- everything's country it'll just
assemble it like this like a 3d printer
mix cells because they can do it
evidently with cells to a certain extent
now they can like 3d print a [ __ ]
well they're talking about making
you know doing meat like that yeah you
know because it's better for the
environment you don't feel like killing
animals and stuff like that you have to
feed a cow yeah you know that's what I
mean and it's chemically exactly the
same yeah you know as well check this
out and if you have that machine then
that means that you can even tap into it
use computer programs to make other
things like make it human I was just
gonna take him yeah well hatching and
make a human body or what if you want
yeah what if you were evil and you
[ __ ] printed it out like a [ __ ]
bioweapon there's just not gonna be any
controls you can't they just can't
control technology technology does
whatever the [ __ ] it wants to do like
now gun control is just totally that's
that's a joke you can 3d print anything
it was always kind of a joke I mean you
can make a loogie submachine gun out of
[ __ ] that you buy out of [ __ ] the
hardware store
just look up Lutie submachine gun on
youtube even make the springs everything
barrel everything the magazines and then
they say well what about that what about
the [ __ ] ammo the ammo is [ __ ]
late 18-hundreds technology you can make
that too they're not just cellulose
based powder the mercury fulminate
[ __ ] priming compounds just there's a
way around all that you can make
anything well everything has a loophole
you're right you can't stop you with
21st century technology you cannot stop
18th and 19th century technology it's
easy to do now I can do things at the
home that couldn't you couldn't do 300
years ago 40 years ago this is one thing
that always kind of blows my mind what
if you invented a time machine and you
went back just a hundred years yeah even
just a hundred years over 200 years and
you brought a person from then to now
they'd be [ __ ] astounded because I
don't know if they'd be able to handle
it no I don't think they would I don't
think my great grandparents or
grandparents could handle what was going
on right now yeah and they were like
they saw it happen yeah they saw the
progression I don't I can't run or
imagine my grandmother okay my
grandfather and grandmother on my
mother's side no problem because my
grandfather worked for [ __ ] Grumman a
Grumman aerospace and [ __ ] he was
involved in the space but my brain knew
all that [ __ ] yeah these space people
you know they knew all there
[ __ ] he knew about I told Rob about
there was [ __ ] my grandfather was
involved in for a kiss he contracted out
to a lot of companies there was a
company called General Atomics that he
worked for for a while and he was on
that Orion program yeah he did some [ __ ]
with that and there's a lot of [ __ ] that
the public doesn't know about [ __ ]
atomic propulsion there's they were it
was way in advance to what they're
telling the public had it gone what you
saw in the Kubrick movie 2001 was
absolutely accurate that's where
technology should have been in 2001 had
they kept going in that direction
but they stopped going in that direction
at least in public we know me with his
big space stations and going out to
Jupiter within a year so you know I mean
a couple years he could do it I don't
remember how long it took them to get to
Jupiter in 2001 six years something
better no Ryan could get there and move
about 16 months yeah [ __ ] yeah anyway
um but my grandmother on my father's
side she couldn't handle it if she saw
the Internet that would have [ __ ]
just no don't just locked up I don't
think she would have been able to
comprehend it and then once she did
comprehend it she wouldn't like the
impacts of the [ __ ] because it from
her point of view that would have been
uncontrollable filth about porn which it
kind of is how can you raise children in
a world where there's uncontrollable
filth that's good because now everybody
just looks at her like myth and then
they're like how can you have something
how do you rate this this is all art
this is all r-rated how do you control
because that was the mentality of the
time and change doesn't happen because
people change their ways change happens
because people die off yeah that's where
progress comes and the weird thing is
that I mean we both remember we're both
Generation X so we both remember like
you know I was I had graduated high
school before the internet was a thing
really so um I didn't really have it
until until I was out of college I don't
think and you know but even I mean to me
it just didn't really seem that big a
deal it's like when you stop to think
about it like
what we have now compared to like what
we have then it's kind of mind-blowing
but I guess because I kind of saw every
step along the way I was just kind of
like oh of course that's like the next
logical step but it really does seem
like you know people of you know the
generation before us or maybe like our
grandparents age or something like that
they just couldn't it just seemed like a
step too far they wouldn't really when I
was a kid I saw cartoons that had Dick
Tracy and Dick Tracy had a damn watch
they had a little TV in it he could talk
to way to somebody else and that was
like something matter that was just
fantasy but now our phones would blow
that away the Star Trek communicator
that was [ __ ] mind-blowing well even
in the in the 70s in the 80s when I was
watching us up whether it be great but
now you know that Kirk's communicating
now everybody's got one and no one gives
a [ __ ] know you talked about you had the
whole internet the whole idea I mean but
it's like it's just so ubiquitous that
it's like the whole idea of having
basically the sum of human knowledge or
access to it in your pocket your pocket
that just that was mind-blowing that's
what I mean if you think about it like
that it's crazy but it's like because
it's so common now and here's like you
don't really think about it and then the
emergent properties that came from it
here's the thing in the 80s when I first
started getting into guns I read the gun
magazines you know like a [ __ ] you
know guns and ammo and if we're gonna
salt rifle magazine and [ __ ] like that
and the guys that were in the gun scene
would [ __ ] we're all spread apart and
they weren't able to talk to each other
very much so kind of like philosophy of
firearms and the equipment that goes
along with it was a evolving very slowly
it was in the hands of corporations like
the cult cult manufacturing and Smith &
Wesson and they were very retro they
were guys that came up in the 50s and
[ __ ] you know they weren't very
forward-thinking now I go on YouTube and
see all these dudes with coming up with
all these different ideas and they're
all talking to each other it's the rate
of [ __ ] acceleration and research its
orders of magnitude faster yeah orders
them and this is not just guns it's
every [ __ ] subject I didn't using
that just as an example archaeology
history
Buchan even health science and [ __ ]
biochemistry everything is moving a lot
faster now
because everyone can see what everybody
else is doing yeah and everyone it's now
like a hive mind
janna and information flow is [ __ ]
fast and it's good quality information
to technology the emergent the emerging
technologies that are going to come from
this the powers that be are afraid of
that's why they're trying to live it our
numbers I'm getting right back to that
agent they're coming out now openly
saying the only way to save the earth is
to reduce the population what's his name
who's that [ __ ] big old fat dude
Michael the guy who did like Bowling for
Columbine no more Michael Moore Michael
Moore just released one saying that
green technologies are [ __ ] that that's
just pie in the sky and that'll never
happen the only way to save the earth is
to reduce the population so that's the
way and that's its mouth that's going
back to Malthusian ideas and that's what
they're doing that's what they're gonna
try to do and so we gotta stop them
don't let them do that because their
thinking is very narrow-minded they
think there's only one earth there's
gonna be many earths soon you can make
Mars into an earth you can make
satellites you can make [ __ ]
interstellar spacecraft all that [ __ ]
will come you know I don't think that
shit's a maybe maybe a hundred years
away if on on current trajectory there's
gonna be some kind of breakthrough in
physics and you're gonna see [ __ ] kind
of like warp drive or way and it's like
that's why I feel like I don't they
worried about [ __ ] that they don't need
to worry well that's what I mean that's
why I don't really like make predictions
about what I think is gonna happen in
the future anything like that because
it's like you know we could be five
years away from some big huge [ __ ]
yeah
earth-shattering [ __ ] discovery
that's gonna change everything and it's
gonna get wildly off in some other
trajectory that we didn't predict as
[ __ ] crazy as I am I'm actually very
optimistic I don't believe in limits or
limitations you have some people are
genetically programmed to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] and downers ago oh my god you
can't colonize another planet you're
ruining another world and you're [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] you can make another planet
out of a [ __ ] ball of rock just like
they showed it for the alien - and then
take all the [ __ ] the tiger Kings
/ - that [ __ ] planet or somebody
decent will take where the Tigers can
live on a new [ __ ] planet this is not
just about mankind this is about all the
[ __ ] life on this planet
it is our not only our right it is our
duty as a [ __ ] species to create new
worlds not only for us but for our
animals they got a right to live - they
doing people don't think about that when
you think about colonization of another
plant things just people and [ __ ]
cities and [ __ ] like that
well you're thinking that he hit Earth
terms you need cities because you have
high population densities and [ __ ] high
population density is not the way to go
it's better to spread out the spread out
so everything's like a suburb or a
country or the wilderness and you have
people and animals let your Tigers go
let them run that the Bears go let them
let them have a place to live they might
eat an occasional person because because
you're you're allowing life to spread
and to live and I think that's a good
thing yeah because check this out what
happens to those Tigers what happens to
those bears eventually do they evolved
into a sentient being
they might might take hundreds of
millions billions of years but that's
okay you're not on different planets
they might eventually you're seating
them to become another species yeah so
let everything [ __ ] live there's not
enough room here so let's spread the
[ __ ] out that's that's so what I'm
talking about and we need some kind of
like Starfleet yeah that's what you need
I'd be I'd be down for that and the new
surveys there are earth-like planets
[ __ ] everywhere they're just
everywhere now quarter these surveys and
there's a lot of them they're close to
Earth that could probably be turned into
a earth there's gonna be emergent
technologies that can do that and it's I
probably won't live long enough to see
it but it's like always gonna go anyway
I do think it's definitely gonna get
that's why you know like you got the
tiger king he's kind of [ __ ] over
those Tigers but they are alive the best
way to keep the tiger genome alive
probably is to have them in captivity
until someday you can release them yeah
no thing to do is maybe like freeze
their DNA and genomes and then
one day bring him I thought of doing
that what do I do
I think they do do that with them with
species that are you know
yeah really in danger every species
every animal here are they should have
its genome in a database that's what I
would do that way if you have to reseed
this planet after like a [ __ ] impact
of a [ __ ] you know a meteor or some
kind of catastrophe that you could Creek
create the life again all of it probably
be good to have the bacteria the the
[ __ ] all the little plankton of the
ocean all that you should have all that
stored somewhere so you could bring it
back one day yeah that's what I would do
I read somewhere that some at least one
country was doing that I think it was
yeah they were doing it with seeds yeah
that's right
yeah that's good yes that's good just in
case of I meant your impact but mankind
will not survive on for long if it just
stays on one planet it has to be in
several planets and eventually several
solar systems that because planets don't
live forever
stars malfunction they get hit by
[ __ ] foreign bodies like big [ __ ]
comets planets don't last for a long
time really and in the big scheme in a
human lifetime yeah it's a long time but
in the grand scheme of things planets
are cut they're just temporary yeah so
you have to kind of colonize as much as
many planets as you can that way you
would ensure the survival of things that
were came off this planet and then you
have to stop the advancement of [ __ ]
AI and living robots if you make living
robots they'll wipe us out just like IO
Terminator we will be obsolete instantly
because they're superior to us yeah
they're immortal they're smarter than us
they don't have any needs and either
they just leave on their own or they say
[ __ ] these things man these biological
to this back feature we're gonna kill
these these are inferior parasites well
we came out of single-sex goddamnit
animals came out of a world of
single-celled organisms we look at them
as just like
our sights and [ __ ] well that's the way
I would see us yeah that we're just
parasites yeah you know that they're the
next step in evolution so you actually
have to prevent AI like they did in dune
yeah they made a new eagle to a certain
extent some yeah you could have but you
couldn't have any kind of ai ai that can
rival the human mind yeah that's what
you have to get away from because then
what would you need a human for you you
not a goddamn thing
no you just make like the things David
like a David robot and then if you had a
world filled with David's as
good-looking as smart as that
[ __ ] was it couldn't be laid and
then you got the corset be [ __ ] you
taking all the hook and women man and
then if you had female ones and [ __ ]
like that all the dudes of gravitate
towards those we brought in so there
goes your [ __ ] there goes your
reproduction immortal woman's or a
living women's sexual market value would
fall down to the [ __ ] floor because
you could have a supermodel who could
beat your ass and do superhuman [ __ ]
with an intent with a genius-level
intelligence of an outstrip any human
you can't have that yeah yeah it's too
dangerous
yeah well it'll be interesting to see
how it was like in the it'll eventually
get to that and then maybe 40 years I
have I think I think 20 well doubt I'm
saying I had I have probably about 40
years before I drop dead they basically
have the bodies now yeah I know just you
just got to have a good enough AI
algorithm and a connection into a damn
internet with the thing and [ __ ] the
right program to get to walk around and
[ __ ] servos so it knows what's up and
down like at equilibrium and that bit
should be walking around in the end I've
seen some of the military stuff that
Ness is 15 years old it looked good it
looks real good
I could imagine if you could put that
nowadays into the power requirements are
a little high yeah but they'll get
around but yeah I'm sure that's another
problem that will be solved because you
know but the way technology is going
nowadays the way to do it is with a new
small nuclear reactor some kind of
nuclear pile which that sounds scary to
the average person but you could do it
yeah there's ways to do it you just have
to make sure that it's in a very solid
containment
you know very small nuclear reactor
running a steam engine to [ __ ] make
electrical power yeah that's kind of how
they had in thx 1138 yeah but that's
that would that would work you just have
to make sure nobody could get their
hands on that nuclear material
yeah and that's that's why that's why it
doesn't exist because if you buy a
nuclear powered car or something like
that like they were thinking about doing
you're giving someone nuclear material
like we do I can make it thirty right
okay sit down I know you've gone too
long all this I'm happy okay I'm trying
to entertain you all right so it's
Friday hopefully you guys have a good
evening and we'll talk to you again
tomorrow